رغم تاكيدها مرارا وتكرارا بانه كان
لاغراض الارصاد الجويه لم تقتنع واشنطن
بالروايه الصينيه حول المنطاد الذي اخترق
سمائها فاسقطته بعد ايام من الشد والجذب
في اروقه ادارتها وهاهم اليوم مسؤول
الاستخبارات في الولايات المتحده يعملون
على اجراء مزيد من التحقيقات حول المنطاد
والانظار تتجه الى هذا الرجل
[موسيقى]
باحث صيني مرموق في جامعه بيهنك نال شهاده
الدكتوراه في تخصص الميكانيكي البنيويه
عام
يرجح ان يكون واحدا من المع عقول التقنيه
والابتكار في بلاده ويعتقد انه العقل
المطور للمنطاد الذي شغل العالم
برز ويزي بشكل كبير في بحوث الفضاء لا سيب
الفضاء القريب اي الحيز الموجود فوق مستوى
تحليق الطيران التجاري واسفل المنطقه التي
توجد فيها الاقمار الاصطناعيه وقبل اربع
سنوات كشف عن تصميم جسم طائر مسير يعتقد
انه المنطاد الذي اسقط في الولايات
المتحده
فريقنا طور جسما طائرا مسيرا يستطيع
التحليق حول العالم بما في ذلك امريكا
الشماليه
تقارير غربيه قالت ان الجسم الطائر الذي
تحدث عنه الباحث الصيني قبل سنوات يحلق
على العلو نفسه للمنطاد لكن السلطات
الامريكيه لم تؤكد شيئا بهذا الصدد حتى
الان وزاره تجاره الامريكيه كانت فرضت
عقوبات على خمس شركات صينيه الى جانب معهد
بحثي على اثر الاشتباه في صله تلك
المؤسسات بما قيل انه برنامج بكين للتجسس
من علو كبير
وبحسب مجله الامريكيه فان اكثر من نصف
المؤسسات الجديده المشموله بالعقوبات
لديها علاقات مع العالم ويزي
المفاجات بحسب صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
الاستخبارات الامريكيه كانت على درايه
بشان التحرك المنطاد الصيني منذ لحظه
اطلاقه وليس بعد دخوله اجواء بلادها وانها
حرصت على مراقب ته عن كثب الى حين عبوره
اجواء الولايات المتحده واتخاذ قرار
باسقاطه
وفي مقاله السلطات الامريكيه انها تفادت
اسقاط المنطاد في بعض المناطق خوفا من
مخاطر السقوط المحتمله تحدثت تقارير اخرى
عن تاخر الخطوه بدافع رصد الاشارات
المنبعثه من المنطاد ومعرفه المزيد عن
طريقه تحركه بشكل عام تنظر الولايات
المتحده بكثير من الارتياب الى الصعود
الصيني المتسارع في مجال التقنيه خصوصا ان
التقديرات جامعه جورج ساون تشير الى ان
عدد الحاصلين على شهاده الدكتوراه في تخصص
العلوم بالصين سيصل في عام 2005
الى ضعف عدد الخريجين في هذا المجال في
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]